your itunes steal how did this come
about did you use an aggregator or no I
got referred into the company and I
can't publicly say yet because they
haven't announced the release date they
said once this company said basically
once we give you a release date you'll
be able to do a press release and
announce it and say who we are and who
we were associated with his stuff so
until then I'm not allowed to say but
they said spring to 30 2013 the spring
is coming out and then once that is I'll
be able to tell who they are but I got
referred in someone else I'll make a
friend of mine introduced me through
email to the people that run in and said
Oh Sherman song it actually I was
introduced to them before we even won
the Phoenix Film Festival we where we
world premiered so they looked at her
film before we even hit the film
festival circuit and they wanted to sign
me and so I was very lucky so that by
the by the time we were in Phoenix I was
already signed and so the whole festival
circuit I wasn't worried about finding a
distributor and you know digital digital
distributor and I was like a good
feeling to be able to like to go around
and not be like kind of you know that
look of desperation like I need
distribution and kind of thing you know
and it's again for me it's the as I've
been learning and as probably everybody
knows it's it's about who you know and
who knows you and getting those
referrals with little introductions
those chance meetings or those people
that they tell you you should meet this
person or I liked your film I'm going to
introduce you to this person it's it is
a business about that
since so much of life is that you know
that desperation does turn people off
it's like dating for a job whatever it
is would he tell people that may be in
that situation but they need to kind of
keep their cards to their festival
present themselves or they're not over
youth her right it may be truly belong
so I think sometimes that they can have
a great product or film whatever but
sometimes that over-eagerness right
right I guess I've been lucky because I
had other people validate my film so I
had my friend was a sales aging so he
saw the film and then he referred me to
the distributor so it's sometimes it's
not always you always doing like if
you're the one doing it you might not be
so aggressive about it you know you
might point out certain things about
like the film is screened here to win
this award or whatever or it's just a
quick and creeks having email or
something but I'm not sure again if it's
such a hard sale because I do get people
hitting me up with you know scripts and
if it's a hard sell you know and if you
if you believe in it so much kind of
question like why is it taking so long
to get it
it's so good you know and you'd want to
be that kind of person so it's always
good night I don't know like I think
some other people to validate it and
social proof possibly like that's what's
weird like you know I can hear the flip
side already the people watching me like
I mean you don't need other people tell
your movies good you believe your movies
good so it's like there's a fine a fine
balance you awfully obviously have to
believe in it to give it to your friend
life it'll like it is extended to to
whoever you know and you have to set out
trying to make the best film possible
and believing in that and it is that
type of world that there is that type of
validation that's needed from some
someplace else whether it is a friend or
a festival or a critic or something
because it's an art and artists
objective but if you have some type of
write-up about it from someplace else I
think that always helps with these kind
of power these you know these people
that control the gatekeepers kind of
thing
you